[Music]
here in this video we will discuss three
things firstly how big was konju and
ahmed during their final battle
secondly who is the third personality
called jake lockley and are they still
moon knight
lastly we will take a look at kanchu is
he really the bad guy so with the
conclusion of the first season we now
know more about these gods so subscribe
if you haven't already and now let's get
to it
let's start with ahmed's description we
all know from the previous episodes that
ahmed was another deity of vengeance but
her form of justice is kind of like
prepaid she judges the sins of the
individual before it is committed so in
the final season in the season finale we
finally get to see her in action her
stone ushabti was finally broken and she
was released
she resembles a large crocodile that
walks on two legs and has the fine
egyptian royal garments and she could
definitely have gone to the met gala
okay bad joke she also has long braided
hair behind her back
her head and also a very long prehensile
tail which she can use for combat
all in all i could say that it was a
very good design and appearance of ahmed
in the mcu
so let's go now to conscious release and
his first fight scene immediately after
ahmed's release from her ushabti layla
got a hold of conscious stone statue and
broke it contour right then and there
realized that mark wasn't on the earthly
plane anymore and had died so he
requested layla to be his avatar to
which she gladly refused he then
disappeared and confronted ahmed by
himself to which he was seen to be
inferior in physical power against the
crocodile goddess he was smacked around
and could only retreat in order to
search for a revived mark
in the meantime the power of the gods
were revealed when ahmed began consuming
the souls of the people of egypt when
konchi was away she started to grow
exponentially in size like kaiju's size
and scale but wasn't just her konchu
later on also confronted her in his own
gigantic form although a bit shorter
than ahmed it was kind of like a
godzilla vs kong fight scene with ahmed
being a giant crocodile similar to
godzilla and konju being the good guy
and holding a weapon kinda like kong but
how big were they really in the show at
their maximum sizes let's get to their
estimates
so originally both conscious and ahmed
before growing out of proportions are
generally taller than humans
but are around nine feet tall like three
meters or so but in the pyramid battle
scenes when they were gigantic they were
although not as tall as the two big
pyramids of giza in one of the scenes
when moon knight was arriving on the
battlefield
we could see ahmed standing close to the
pyramid of kafri and she was around two
thirds of its height and given that this
pyramid is around 140 meters or 460 feet
in height
therefore she would be around 95 meters
or 311 feet tall
concho would also be around the same
size but a bit shorter maybe around 90
meters or 300 feet
this is still just a rough estimate from
minecube but the officially released
size would not be that far off i think
okay now so let's get to the next
question who is this jake lockley well
in the final fight scenes between moon
knight and layla who is now tower its
avatar versus arthur harrow who is now
the avatar of ahmed there was a moment
where both mark spector and steven grant
blacked out and harrow was defeated in
combat
but both of them don't remember anything
even later on after waking up in their
apartment in london in the end
they were just blacked out the truth was
later revealed in the end credit scenes
where harrow was dragged into a car
that concho was in
and he was killed by a guy named jake
lockley who surprisingly enough controls
the body of mark spector
can't you although granting mark and
steven the wish of being released as his
avatar was still in the shadows
controlling the body via another
personality named jake lockley
he is a more violent and far deadlier
persona able to kill without a hint of
guilt he was seen to kill harrow in the
end credit scenes and was the one who
defeated all the others during the final
fight scenes in egypt and was probably
the one who ousted the other guys
chasing stephen graham in the first
episodes in switzerland
well more about him will be revealed in
the next season if it is confirmed or
continued
so with all this happening is can't you
really the bad guy well the answer is
both yes and no concho is kind of like a
morally grey character he does what he
does for the greater good of humanity
but doesn't really take into
consideration the feelings and
consequences of his avatar that has to
suffer conscious was banished by the
other gods for being a vigilante among
them and the last part of the series
shows how he really is like his
vigilante kind of persona
he would do anything to attain his goal
well not anything blatantly evil but
nevertheless dark he has also shown his
good side when he sacrificed himself to
help layla and mark to discover amid
stone before being imprisoned
so yeah he is kind of like a morally
grey character or just a force of nature
that can't be controlled
anyway with that we come to the end of
the video so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the minecube family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam